foreign
[Music]
professor at Children's Hospital Los
Angeles first of all I would like to
thank the organizer for giving me this
opportunity to present our work and
today I'm going to talk about the
glomalous and a chip as a platform for
disease modeling drug screening
biomarker discovering and mechanistic
studies
foreign
let me just tell you a little bit about
the kidney in the kidney then iPhones
are the filtration unit of the kidney
and are composed by glomer illusion
tubers in adults there are no new Nerf
information and that means that lots of
Naval function leads to development of
chronic kidney disease a condition that
affects about 14 percent of Americans
that are located at the opposite side of
the glomerular basal membrane all these
three components are extremely important
and essential for the function of the
kidney
and damage to one of them leads to
injury and defects in all the others
why is it creating a glomerulus so
difficult there are three main reasons
the first one is an architectural
challenge these three components that we
were saying are closely in contact and
there and this allows intellectual and
continuous cost stock
and the second reason is the source of
the cells it has been a very uh
problematic issue in many fields and in
the kidney it makes no exception and
this is particularly true for both sides
and the third reason is that most of the
studies and the knowledge that we have
about the kidney comes from sadism mice
and as we have learned and we will keep
learning mice are different from humans
and what we might understand in mice
might be useful by might not be
sufficient for our understanding of
human physiology
to solve the further first issue we um
we try different approaches uh we
started in the beginning with the 2D
approaches in a plate or maybe 3D
systems like hanging drops but they
didn't work very well
um luckily
um very recently there's been the huge
development of systems that are known as
microfluidic systems that are the basis
for the development of organella chips
and we decided to use a commercially
available organ on a chip that is made
by three channels as you can see in the
central panel challenge that in our
system we call cenf and I will explain
the reason about that later on in the
presentation
this system allows control of Channel
feeling taking advantage of surface
tension and the formation of a mini
schools by collagen that can be loaded
in Channel e
that is E4 extracellular Matrix in our
system we decided to try an approach
that would allow us to seed the cells
without the presence of any membrane in
between the two cell types in fact there
are different glomerular chip systems
that are that have been developed by our
colleagues but most of them present the
two cells that are seated on two
different on the opposite side of a
Pollos membrane as I was mentioning
before
products are closely in contact and we
were trying to mimic these uh specific
and as you can see here we use the
cellular the the collagen uh as just a
backbone for support of uh
um the seeding of podocytes a single
layer of protocytes on top of which we
see the glomelo in the tubular cells
this allows us to don't have any
membrane in between the two cell layers
the second issue was the sourcing of the
cells in our work we decided to try
different type different types of
product sites we started with human
amniotic fluid alive that photocytes
because during development of the fetus
the magnetic fluid contains a lot of
cells from different organs that we have
shown before we were able to isolate the
clinical genitors based on the selection
for cd24 or because
and we were able to show that we are
able to differentiate these cells and
acquire a morphology that is compatible
with one of photocytes expression of
photocyte marker like nephrine producing
and wt1 and also more important in
collagen full production collagen full
Alpha 3 4 and 5 are the main
constituents of the glomerular basal
membrane and they are produced only by
protocytes in the kidney we also
confirmed that these cells were really
photocelled by functional study
including a response to toxicity
response to Angiotensin and cell cycle
analysis
we also wanted to use two protocites and
so we developed the system to isolate by
my body size and glomerular cells from
kidneys that are discarded for
transplantation
the skin genes that are not presenting
any damage that is the peculiar of
kidney disease where digested that to
obtain
glomeruli and from the glomerular we
isolate the cd31 cells that identify
glomerang.us cells and therefore in
positive cells that identified
protocytes we have performed a very wide
analysis of this cells to confirm the
phenotype we also use the golden golden
standard of photocytes that are
immortalizing human protocytes those are
the photos that have been used for many
years for studying podocytes in vitro
so the first thing that we did was we
decided to uh code uh to sit down the
podocytes and look at uh how well they
were performing in the uh in our
glomeration chip and as you can see here
all three lines were able to maintain
expression of methylene confirming that
this photo size well uh well maintaining
the phenotype and uh they were
we also see that only human glamela
endothelial cells using a specific
glomerular endothelial cell media and we
let them go confluent and form a
capillary-like structure as you can see
from the panel B in our figure you can
see that the uh the the red the red
fluorescent cells are able to form a
capillary that you see in Channel c
channel C is not is is called C just for
capillary and you confirm that with the
seismantine expression of cd31 and
respond to
um to standing for with germa glutamine
that identifies the glycocolics
so once we have proven that these two
sites were able to be calculated alone
we decided to put them together and so
we see that first the photo size and
after 24 hours we added the glomerular
in the two cells as you can see from the
pictures here these two cells form two
layers that are contiguous and are in
contact so just in that they are able to
interact very well we have shown that
this is a particularly true for the
human amniotic fluid protocytes and for
the primipotocytes immortalized
photocytes I have to say responded a
little bit less well to our system
uh we also wanted to confirm that
together with the two layers to those
two cellular layers of the glomerular
affectation barrier we were able to find
the government available membrane that
is the third important component of the
humanification bar as you can see here
we have confirmed the expression of
collagen within four Alpha 4 and
collagen 4 Alpha 5 as well as lamini
Alpha 5 and what is important is is that
this one is a the novel production
because there is no collagen fall of any
kind in our chip before this evening
so one we have shown that our uh chips
uh are able to maintain the appearance
of being a government reputation barrier
like but are they really working like a
gumarification barrier and one of the
most important roles of the glomeratives
is to prevent protein loss from the
blood and in fact botinoia is normally
used in the clinic to assess renal
damage and so our question was if we
were our system was able to retain
protein on channels that is the
capillary Channel
as you can see here what we did was we
added Fitzy albumin that is to the
perfusion channel that is channel C at
the physiological concentration of 40
milligram per ml that is the
concentration that we find in the human
blood as you can see in the first three
panel b c and d
the the albumin is retained on the
channel C without flowing through the
channel e and the channel f channel f is
called like that because it's no is what
we use to collect the filter it that's
why channel f
um and so the reason for the maintenance
of the albumin in Channel C was
definitely the presence of the cells
because we when we added the albumin to
uh chip with collagen but no cells the
argument was diffuse diffusing
immediately uh into channel into the
other channels the same happened when we
were substituting lamella in the trigal
cells with human lung and the TSS over
we were substituting protocytes with the
human fibrillas suggesting that
the not only the presence of cells but
the presence of the light cells is
essential for uh for the function of the
glomerular filtration barrier in Vito as
we designed it as you can see here we
also perform the statistical analysis
and we confirmed that the telephotosides
line with the glomeran in the USA as
well outperforming all the other
conditions
we also perform long-term personality
assessments over 28 days and we
performed this albumin test every week
and as you can see here primary
podocytes and and human amniotic fluid
podocytes uh generated chip systems we
are able to maintain
an album selectivity over time while a
human immortalized photo sites were
losing very quickly their ability to
retain album we also checked about
Dozier 28 days and this one is just a
representative picture but we performed
it for the three lines we didn't see
really uh uh apoptosis after 28 days
suggesting that I was still viable for a
long time
so that being done we decided to look at
some response to enjoy and the first
system that we uh used was the
nephotoxin injury caused by pure
medicine Amino nucleosido pan
is a very well known and photographic
agent that is able to damage the
podocytes disarranging that for the side
cytoskeletal leading to disruption of
this lead diaphragm the Z diaphragm that
is an essential composite
component of the podocytes layer
as you can see here after addition of
the
um of the mode of the pumizing amino
nucleoside we have a desertion of the
cytoskeleton as you can see in panel in
the panel on the right with formation of
those classic wings so that uh Define
damage in the protocytes when we did
that in the in the cheaper we have we
were indeed able to uh cause a response
in all the three cell lines and with the
loss of albumin that is shown in panel K
and NQ after 60 minutes and we also
showed that there was a disruption of
the cytoskeleton bystaining we for a
factor
we were very intrigued by our response
by the response of our system to enjoy
and we decided to see if we were able to
use this system to model different
kidney diseases
the first one that we chose was
membranous nephropathy in members
nephropathy that is an autoimmune
disease the body develops antibodies
against proteins that are normally
exposed by photocytes
um mostly uh the target proteins are
pla2r or Thomas even though there are
many other proteins that are being
discovered lately this uh this uh
binding of antibodies against proteins
leads to the position of immunocomplex
that leads to podocyte injury protein
and ultimately original failure
the first thing that we wanted to
confirm was that our protocyte lines
while expressing pla-12 and indeed all
the three lines were expressing pla 12
that is the Target that we have chosen
however please notice that the
immortalized photocytes that are on the
in the central
in in the center well it's passing a
lower amount of pla2r and this becomes
important when we will look at the
results afterwards
we also confirmed that by following the
addition of 0.5 percent as human theorem
from patients suffering from membranous
the property within the chip we were
able to show that there was both the
position of total and IGG for uh total
Iggs and Iggs for suggesting that indeed
the the antibodies present in the human
pneumonia well able to Target the
podocytes and bind them we also
confirmed that this was leading to an
increase in loss of methane
that is an essential protein that is uh
Paramount for the function of the
protocytes
when we went and looked at the
functional effect of pla 12 binding to
to the on the chip we found that
compared to chips where the Sierra was
coming from healthy healthy controls
this year from membranous navratic
patients was able to take a response
that was leading to albumin loss in the
in the chip this one was true
particularly for the amniotic fluid
protocytes and the primary protocytes
while the the immortalized photocytes
were not responding as well this could
be though possibly because of the lack
of a high expansion of pla-12 in this
cell line
we were very excited to see that we were
able to find and explain any response
from to of the cheap from Amazon
but we were even more excited when we
went back we looked at the correlation
between the proteinuria that we were
measuring on the chip and the patinoia
on the patients at the time of the blood
uh doing as you can see here
both for the kidney protocites and the
primary protocites we were able to find
the clear correlation a high correlation
between the measurement on the chip and
the measurement in the potential of the
patient suggesting that we can use this
system not only to this to model disease
the property as a disease but also as a
potential that enough tool that
replicates very well what is happening
in Vivo
we also wanted to confirm that our
system was specific and so we chose uh
we chose to
expose our chips to the Sierra of
different kidney diseases including fsgs
these samples were from patients in
remission so they were not known to have
were not expected to have any uh any
molecule or anything that would trigger
a response we also tested the Siva from
alpha patients in this case above
patients is a genetic disease when we
talk more about that later but it is not
known to contain anything in the blood
that would cause uh producer damage and
we also looked at CFM patients from
polycystic kidney disease
and as you can see from our results none
of those here I was able to trigger the
response and the loss of albumin
suggesting that our system is very
specific
and the response to uh specific damages
that are uh and not adjusted to humans
here a person
we also wanted to confirm that our
system was
potentially user useful for drug testing
in particular in the proclinical
environment and so we decided to test
the alpha msh that is a asth an analog
that is being used for the treatment of
membranos nephropathy when
corticosteroids are not efficient and in
our case the alpha Milano coating one
hormone was able to lower and prevent
the loss of albumin in our chips when it
was administered at the same time with
the uh with the immense patients here
suggesting that indeed we can use our
systems also to study the response to
drugs and how how efficiently this drug
could rescue patients before moving to
clinical trials
as I mentioned before we are gonna go a
little bit more in detail about Alpo
syndrome Alpo syndrome is a genetic
disease that is caused by defecting the
production of collagen fall in
particularly collagen 4 Alpha 3 4 or 5.
doing normal development in our kidneys
we start with
um with the presence of collagen alpha
one and two in the glomerulus and in the
glomerular filtration barrier but over
time this collagen 4 Alpha 1 and 2 is
substituted by collagen for Alpha 34 M5
that becomes predominant in during
adopness however in Alpha syndrome where
there is degenetic disease what is
happening is that the body is unable to
make the switch and substitute the
collagen for Alpha 1 and 2. this leads
to uh defective glomerular Basin
membrane as as I was mentioning before
when there is one defect one of the
components of the gramular Basin
membrane and the global notification
barrier all of the other components are
affected and indeed the podocytes and
glomerular endothelial cells in Albert
syndrome are affected by these defects
and membrane and this leads to a split
thickened basket with numeral membrane
as you can see in the picture on the
right by scanning electron microscopy
so to model this one we were lucky
enough that we were able to obtain
amniotic fluid from a fetus that was
carrying a mutation for collagen for
Alpha 4 using the same approach that we
use to isolate the humanity food
clinical genital we isolated
filipogenitors from these output
patients by yes by coexpression of cd24
orbicadaing and protocolaxin and there
are about less than one percent of the
sites are expressed in these markers and
we were able to to expand them
um expand them before differentiation
once we use use the dose defective
protocytes on the chip we were able to
show that the this photo site they were
carrying this mutation for collagen 4
while leading to the production of the
defective GBM leading to both protein on
the chip as you can see on the panel on
the light and this one was a statistical
statistically significant different
foreign
we also decided to look at diabetic
nephropathy that is a very common damage
for the kidneys in particular due to the
high incidence of diabetes in our
populations and as you can see here when
we add a sufficiently high glucose
amount in the media and this one was 20
minimola we were able to show that after
72 hours we were able to trigger a
damage that was leading to uh to
to um two laws of albumin
in conclusion I would like to say that
we have successfully established a
buyer-free system that is formed by
human podocytes and human glomerular and
critical cells and we do that by using a
three different human protocytes lines
and deposits like salsa and Twee main
compartmentalized and interact while
maintaining the specific identities we
have also found evidence of the position
of a glomerular business and like
structure in our system based on the
production of collagen 4 Alpha 34 M5 and
laminine Alpha 5. more importantly we
have shown that the newly formed grammar
application barrier structure is
impermeable to albumin and is accessible
to enjoy this one leads to a damage to
the filtration barrier that again leads
to increased permeability to argument
and this one suggests that our system is
feasible for toxicity studies our system
is we have shown in our model of
membranous nephropathy is patient
specific and the results highly
correlated with clinical data our system
is also versatile we have shown that we
can model different diseases including
diabetic poverty various conic
disease and it can be used for disease
modeling and our system is also feasible
for platform uh as a platform for dark
testing in conclusion I would like to
thank
um everybody that has contributed to
this work that could not be done without
the support of our chief logic Philippe
and my colleague Laura perinde pivotal
role in the development of this system
and all the people that are worked in
this in this project including Dr Zhang
droplet generator I cannot forget our
collaborators both at USC and around the
US and in Europe and in conclusion um I
can I would like to thank the gophal
kidney fund and the NIH for supporting
our research thank you so much any
questions